[Music]
welcome to architecting with google
cloud i'm developer advocate caslin
fields and today we're going to explore
the architecture of apollo with
engineering lead adam zions welcome adam
thank you i'm really happy to be here
castle so i know apollo provides an
implementation of graphql could you
first tell us a little bit about what
graphql is definitely graphql is an api
technology that helps developers provide
access to all of their data via a graph
interface and ql actually stands for
query language so it's a query language
to get at the data graph and so that
differs from the usual kind of
hierarchical pattern that rest provides
it's been hugely adopted by a lot of
major companies including walmart
expedia netflix airbnb on down the line
and originally came out of facebook to
help provide an api to the social graph
that makes a lot of sense and it sounds
like a lot of businesses are finding
benefits in this style of querying
definitely i think that some of the
some of the biggest benefits of are just
having all of your data in one place
helps to unlock a lot of things first of
all
it cuts down to the amount of redundancy
where if you have all that data there
you're not going to end up recreating
the same thing over and over and second
of all it opens up that data to people
who might want to have access to it who
are interested in engineering people
like product management or sales you're
not able to get into that data
understand how it's you know being used
who is looking at it to help drive the
right kinds of conversations and unlock
the most value for that business
cool so that's a little bit about what
graphql is
so now could you tell us a little bit
about what apollo does with graphql and
what services you offer absolutely
apollo offers
kind of the default implementation of
graphql so we have an open source client
an open source server a number of tools
besides those that all help people get
started with graphql
and scale it up to production as well so
starting to write out web applications
and apis move data from rest or even
just start out new projects in graphql
to prove out the value of it beyond
those kind of table stakes of how to
even get started with graphql and build
we we've invested a lot over the past
couple of years in the idea of apollo
federation which allows distinct teams
to run their own graphql services but
then join them together to provide like
a single unified graph of all of their
data
and so that's also completely free open
source apollo federation that helps big
businesses scale graphql within multiple
teams and then we have a sas application
that helps you
also has a free version up to you know
paid and enterprise
that helps you understand how your
graphql schemas are evolving over time
see who is using your graph and how
and help you to kind of automate out
that build process and keep those teams
in sync without needing to have a lot of
slack communication and email
communication that generally happens
between backend and front end
in order to get that kind of api work
done so graphql is an open source api
and apollo offers clients and servers
which are very popular for use both with
open source and in businesses and then
you offer all of these additional tools
to help make using graphql at scale in
large businesses a lot easier and kind
of make a lot more sense in the
enterprise space like devtools query
monitoring this kind of
uh i don't know how to describe it but
like uh kind of an auditing tool it
sounds like you were describing yeah
yeah so
we are our mission around graphql is to
make sure that we provide all of the
tools that businesses need to be able to
scale and manage their graph in
production safely
awesome so apollo provides a lot of
tools and services to help developers at
these big companies and open source as
well
work with data via graphql and you're
serving a lot of users and companies
how does a user typically start using
apollo's capabilities great question
typically
users get started or companies get
started using graphql and using apollo
bit by bit we very much believe that the
idea of re-architecting and starting
over from step one via some big like
flag day and years of development is not
something that anyone is trying to do in
2022
and we highly recommend that when people
want to start with graphql people want
to get started with apollo they do that
by you know one feature at a time one
application at a time even you know one
page one component at a time when you're
talking about react
and so generally that's how people get
started just as this test case to say
can we take this maybe complicated
feature
and move it over to a graph
and then once there's success in that
you can incrementally iteratively start
adding more and more into that graph
this sounds like a lot of use cases that
i see in the cloud space especially
whenever a business is adopting any kind
of new technology it's always best to
start with maybe one or two
applications that you can start shifting
over to that new technology and then
shift more and more as you see the
benefits and as it makes sense and as
your engineers develop the skills to use
those tools too definitely and
it's very similar to kubernetes even and
very much where that idea of apollo
federation comes from the idea of being
able to move incrementally be able to
segment things off separately but then
bring them together in the end all of
those things are
like very prominent in the space of how
to do technology right given all the
things that we've learned um
and very much the direction that we try
to come at it as apollo awesome so
a lot of businesses will start maybe
shifting something over into graphql
start looking at apollo services
and maybe start moving something over
how does all this work on apollo's side
and where does google cloud fit in
yeah so
our
sas application that i talked about
before that helps track you know which
schemas are being deployed over which
time that helps you to craft out
excellent queries and mutations and
share them with your friends and
colleagues
that gives you insights into who is
using your graph how
all of that
data is hosted inside of google cloud
and the services behind the scenes that
help make all that possible is coming
from google cloud as well um
we we very much believe that our core
competency as a business should be
building excellent graphql tools that
help developers build excellent apps and
not learning how to manage and run
complicated infrastructure so let's talk
a little bit more about this
architecture what are some of the pieces
that go into it both google cloud
products and other types of technologies
that you use to do what you do sure so
we're running most of this atop gke
google kubernetes engine and
on top of that we're using a number of
different databases and stores behind
the scenes um
some things that we're running ourselves
for instance memcached kafka and an olap
data source or database called druid
that helps us manage that time series
data
a lot of things we also use google cloud
for hosting for instance cloud sql which
are using postgres bigtable bigquery pub
sub
spanner is another really big one that
we rely on as well we also have a couple
of services deployed in aws as well so
we can have multi-cloud support for the
most critical aspects of our system um
and i could
go into more detail on any of those
things i think there's a lot of folks
out there who can relate to a lot of
those components of architecture uh
hybrid cloud using kubernetes is of
course very popular and i'm a kubernetes
specialist so of course i would point
that out and
but one thing in there that i found
really interesting is that you're
running your own kafka i hear kafka in a
lot of architectures these days so could
you talk a little bit about why you
decided to run kafka yourselves and how
that's been going for you yeah so i i
laugh because it's like
i wouldn't say a sore subject but i
certainly have battle scars we've been
running kafka over the last few years
and originally when we chose to run our
own kafka it's because there just wasn't
an offering for it on google cloud there
wasn't an offering with gcp
via confluent cloud either um
so we started running our own kafka then
and we have definitely
i think we've reached a point now where
things are pretty stable we're not like
knock on wood but we're not having any
kinds of like crazy outages or
disturbances because running around
kafka but we had to learn a lot of
things
i remember a lot of sleepless nights
just banging our heads against the
proverbial wall trying to figure out
what the heck was going on in particular
there was this one night where i had to
escalate to the cto at the time who was
on sabbatical because
these super blocks inside of the disk
was actually being completely corrupted
because we were going over to 16
terabytes which apparently you can't do
on an xt4 file system meanwhile i'm like
i've been using kafka a few months i had
no idea what's going on i felt like i
learned
much more in that one night about kafka
and about disks
that i had in the previous month but
that being said not something i
particularly want to repeat so that's
the thing that we're actually looking at
right now is how do we migrate to a
cloud provider to make sure that now the
world is kind of caught up with our
usage of kafka there's plenty of options
out there make sure that as we grow out
the size of apollo we're not going to
have to have a kafka team just to manage
that queue
yeah that makes a lot of sense to me and
i think a lot of folks out there can
relate to having some part of their
infrastructure that's just like
we have to run it ourselves because
reasons but
it causes a lot of pain maybe eventually
there are better options
and
you start considering moving over to one
of those newer options so that you can
focus more on your core business rather
than these uh pieces that you have to
run to make the business work that's
right and you know one thing that we've
also started to do over the last year or
so has been just investing more and more
in pubsub so we haven't added a lot into
our kafka queue that's mostly just the
you know quote-unquote legacy stuff
um
and we're starting to think about that
migration after the things that are in
kafka since they're not super compatible
at the moment
cool so one other thing i want to point
out about your architecture is when we
were talking about all of this
uh i found out that you are running
pretty much your your whole business on
a single google kubernetes engine
cluster and as a kubernetes specialist i
found this very interesting and exciting
i'd love to hear more about how that's
going for you and some of the the tools
and kind of tactics that you use to make
a single cluster for uh multiple teams
multiple products even work for you
yeah
another great question
um and you know probably something that
will evolve as we grow like
all of our kubernetes engine and the way
that we've built our back end was
originally out of one team as i'm sure
it is for a lot of folks who have you
know seen huge growth in their companies
and now we have almost a dozen
engineering teams we're planning on
doubling that so i'm sure that a lot of
these things are going to change as we
scale and grow at apollo
but ultimately like being able to have
all of this in one gke cluster has been
pretty advantageous it means that we can
wrap all of our coop cuddle tooling
uh to all work in one way it means that
whenever you're inside of the cluster
you can access logs from multiple
different services or do operations on
multiple different services without
needing to like log in and log out am i
logged into the right one
um a couple of things that we have
done to make sure that we don't have big
problems there is make sure we have
separate namespaces
to match like production and staging
traffic and just
make sure to keep those separate
and
also just having different node pools
because not every service is made the
same so we have a bunch of different
node pools where we can use tapes and
tolerations and just like selectors to
ensure that those services can be
assigned to the correct node pools or in
you know cases like kafka that's just on
its own you don't have like a noisy
neighbor problem where like kafka and
some other thing are all on the same pod
and one is being starved of resources i
want to point out for anyone that's not
familiar with gke we have this concept
of node pools where a single node pool
is all virtual machine instances of the
same type the same kind of hardware
configuration the same pieces there so
then you can use kubernetes taints and
tolerations to manage
where your workloads are run making sure
that they're run on the right hardware
the right machines for that workload
that's right and that's a
you know i say it's all pretty much good
it's kind of a similar story to kafka
like we have learned our hard we've
learned our lessons the hard way
for instance like we in general are okay
with having pods from staging and from
production on the same notes that's not
a huge deal
could be a little scary for instance one
time we were using
local ssds to store a whole bunch of
state and they were just picked up at
the same file path and we ended up
leaking data between staging and
production which had this massive effect
on like wiping out a swath of our
database this was like this was
years ago and we didn't affect any
customer traffic because of it but it
was the most perplexing issue you could
imagine
um and so definitely there is a huge
advantage in keeping things as separate
as possible and as i mentioned before as
we grow out more and more teams our goal
and the way that we think about team
management at apollo is that each team
should be able to own its own stack of
architecture top to bottom as much as
possible and do that independently so
that might mean having you know a
different namespace or even an entire
different cluster per team and being
able to join those things together
across you know some kind of period
awesome i think as you grow like you
said a lot of folks start out with
technologies that work when you're one
team that's trying to do a thing and
then as you start growing more teams
there are all these types of challenges
that you encounter and so you have to
start thinking about different ways to
do things um so that makes a lot of
sense and for me that's that's part of
the fun of this like i remember starting
off in engineering i had this idea of
wanting to do everything perfectly um
and as you get in you're you know months
in you're like okay it's all about
trade-offs you're not going to do the
perfect thing ever you're gonna do the
right thing for the right time and six
months from now it's not gonna be the
right thing anymore nothing lasts and
it's i don't know i find that problem
really fun and interesting of balancing
all those different priorities and
making good decisions and then you know
fixing the airplane as you're in the air
so to speak
awesome so apollo has a lot of
innovation coming up it sounds like as
you grow up more teams you're going to
consider different ways that you're
going to do your
kubernetes architecture we talked about
kafka possibly moving into a managed
service anything else you want to point
out about ways that apollo is kind of
innovating both on their business and on
their infrastructure architecture yeah
those are all really good examples i
think that in general as you grow
and scale out the number of teams that
you have there's a lot like a lot of
people talk about scale and the first
thing that usually comes to mind for me
is like you know what is like the tps
that you're trying to deal with how much
more traffic are you getting but
as i've kind of gone through my career
i've started to think much more of scale
in terms of people how many people can
you have actively collaborating on this
code base on this infrastructure and a
ton of work is going to be done over the
next several over the next six months
over the next year probably ad infinitum
to make that more and more achievable
like we were talking about with
trade-offs before so that means
separating this infrastructure so that
each team can own its own architecture
that means making it easier to deploy
things and have the observability that
you want out of the box that means
starting to use more managed services
instead of hosting things ourselves
we're also we are dealing with that
other side of scale where we have
customers like walmart and netflix and
airbnb on down the line
and you know more and more who are
starting to adopt graphql or starting to
adopt apollo and
being able to
lean in a little bit more to
more event-driven systems making sure
that we have partial degradation rather
than like complete failures in places
starting to do more chaos engineering
there's a lot of
fun things ahead of us
wise to make sure that
we can hit both of those kinds of scale
but the scale that comes from just the
raw growth of traffic as well as the
engineers that we're all collaborating
with now
awesome and speaking of scale and growth
i know that graphql is growing in
popularity of course apollo's offerings
uh
are therefore getting
a boost as well so i'm sure a lot of
folks out there are probably starting to
think about graphql in their businesses
maybe they're uh interested in some of
the features and products that you
mentioned could you tell us where we can
find more about apollo absolutely so the
the best place to start is just our
landing page
apollographql.com we would love for you
to check out studio that sas application
that's at
studio.apollographql.com if you want to
just learn graphql and get started we
actually have a course that we're
offering odyssey
and that's at
odyssey.apollographkill.com
and last but certainly not least we are
doing a ton of hiring so if you want to
work with us you can find that careers
page on our main website apollo
graphql.com careers or just connect with
me directly on linkedin
awesome i love hearing about learning
opportunities too so if you want to
check out any of those awesome things
that adam just mentioned be sure to
check out the links in the description
below
and uh be sure to like and subscribe
thank you so much for being on today
adam and telling us about your
architecture and what apollo is doing
with graphql and google cloud
yeah thank you so much castle it's a it
was a real pleasure to be here and get
to share that with you and it would be
remiss of me to not shout out the
excellent people behind the scenes who
have built up all of this infrastructure
because i can't claim very much credit
myself
as i've moved on to the management side
of the world
so a really huge shout out to the team
that has made all of this possible that
keeps it all running that is on call
and that is doing all this work to make
improvements and come come join us
awesome thank you so much thank you
castle
[Music]
you